Experience Amazing.
JILLIAN: IT IS NOT JUST NEW YORK
BECAUSE GRETCHEN WITMER IS ALSO
FACING INTENSE SCRUTINY FOR HER
HANDLING OF COVID 19 IN NURSING
HOMES AND FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
DEMANDING ANSWERS INCLUDING OUR
NEXT GUEST WHO LOST HER MOTHER,
JAMIE NICHOLSON IS HERE TO SHARE
HER STORY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
SO START TO TALK TO YOU UNDER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES BUT APPRECIATE
YOU GIVING US TIME AND SHARING
YOUR STORY.
LET’S TALK ABOUT YOUR MOTHER.
SHE WAS 76 WHEN SHE PASSED AWAY
AND YOU CARED FOR HER
TREMENDOUSLY AT GREAT LENGTH FOR
16 YEARS AFTER SHE WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH ALZHEIMER’S.
TELLING WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR.
>> WE WORKED SO HARD AND LOVED
MOM SO MUCH CARING FOR HER AND
MARCH 11TH OF LAST YEAR, MOM’S
THERE’S LOCKED US OUT.
DAD AND I WERE PREVENTED FROM
ANY CONTACT FOR 11 MONTHS, THE
FINAL MONTH OF HER LIFE SHE WAS
FACED WITH MORE RESTRICTIONS
MOVED TO A DIFFERENT FACILITY
AND FINALLY DIED OF DEPRESSION
AND LONELINESS.
WE WATCHED HER OVER 11 MONTHS
FADE AWAY AND BY THROUGH A
WINDOW AND ON SCREEN.
JILLIAN: MY HEART BREAKS FOR
YOU.
WHAT WAS THE BEST THING ABOUT
YOUR MOTHER?
TELL ME ABOUT HER.
>> MOM HAD A VIBRANT PERSONALITY
EVEN THOUGH SHE WAS IN DIFFERENT
FACILITIES, FULLY DEPENDENT ON
CARE FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS OF
HER LIFE, EVERYONE AROUND HER
REMARKED THAT HER SMILE, HER
ENERGY, HER LAUGHTER, I WOULD
TAKE HER DANCING IN HER
WHEELCHAIR, SWINGING AROUND AND
CLEARING OUT THE CHAIRS AND
TABLES IN THE CAFETERIA.
SHE WOULD LIGHT UP AND HOLD MY
HAND, DAD WOULD HOLD HER HAND
AND WATCH THEIR FAVORITE SHOWS
TO GATHER EVEN WHEN SHE WAS
INSTITUTIONALIZED.
JILLIAN: SILICA BEAUTIFUL WOMAN
AND YOU CELICA BEAUTIFUL FAMILY.
I WILL KEEP YOU HERE WITH US,
BRING IN THE SPOKESMAN FOR
MICHIGAN’S REPUBLICAN PARTY,
TED, LAWMAKERS ARE REQUESTING AN
INVESTIGATION OF WHAT HAPPENED
HERE AND GOVERNOR WITMER’S
HANDLING OF THIS PANDEMIC.
CAN YOU TELL ME ABOUT WHERE YOU
STAND ON THIS AND HOW YOU ARE
TRYING TO GET ANSWERS?
>> OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO THE
FAMILY AND ALL THE LOVED ONES WE
HAVE LOST OVER THE COURSE OF
THIS PANDEMIC.
THIS STORY IS PLAYING OUT
REPEATEDLY ACROSS THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN AND MANY PARTS OF THIS
COUNTRY.
THE PROSECUTOR ANNOUNCED AT A
PRESS CONFERENCE THAT HE IS
LOOKING FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY
HAVE LOST LOVED ONES INSIDE
NURSING HOMES AND ASSISTED CARE
FACILITIES, WHO FILED POLICE
REPORTS WITH POLICE BECAUSE THE
LAWS DO NOT ALLOW THE PROSECUTOR
TO GAIN ACCESS TO INFORMATION HE
NEEDS TO FIND THE TRUTH ABOUT
NURSING HOME POLICIES AND WHAT
HAPPENED THAT MAY HAVE LED TO
UNNECESSARY AND AVOIDABLE
DEATHS.
SEAN: IT IS HARD TO WATCH THE
FIGHT IN NEW YORK?
ALL OF THE ATTENTION IS
WARRANTED AND DESERVED IN NEW
YORK AND MICHIGAN, WHEREVER ELSE
THIS COULD HAVE HAPPENED, FOR
FAMILIES TO GET ANSWERS BUT A
LOT OF THE FOCUS THE LAST FEW
MONTHS IS BEEN ON NEW YORK AND
JUST NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
MICHIGAN.
DO YOU FEEL YOU ARE A STEP
FORWARD IN TRYING TO GET
ANSWERS?
>> DAD AND I TALK ABOUT THIS
REGULARLY AND IT IS HARD, HARD
FOR US TO TURN ON THE TV.
THE CARDS THAT CAME IN THE MAIL
WITH SYMPATHY BUT ALSO
STRENGTHENS OUR RESOLVE.
IT IS SOMETHING I INHERITED FROM
HER AND LEARNED FROM HER AND I
AM READY.
I WAS TALKING WITH SENATOR JIM
RUNSTEAD, SHE ENCOURAGED ME TO
MOBILIZE PEOPLE AS MUCH AS WE
COULD, WE CAME UP WITH A GROUP
ON FACEBOOK LIKE THE PARENTS OF
ATHLETES WHO ORGANIZE 30,000
PEOPLE AND GOT ON THE STEPS OF
THE CAPITAL AND SHORTLY
THEREAFTER THE GOVERNOR CHANGED
POLICIES THAT ALLOWED THOSE
INDIVIDUALS, WE WANT TO DO THAT,
WE HAVE A FACEBOOK GROUP CALLED
SAVE OUR SENIORS MICHIGAN.
WE ARE ORGANIZING AND IN THIS
FIGHT TOGETHER SO NOBODY HAS TO
GO THROUGH WHAT WE DID.
JILLIAN: GOVERNOR WITMER STANDS
BY THE POLICY, SHE ENDED THAT
PRACTICE AFTER THE FIRST
EXCELLENCE OF THE PANDEMIC.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE YOURSELF